[Music]
for decades now for i guess my whole
lifetime
we have been burdened
with the same old republican candidates
for
president well until trump for senate
for governor for everything down to dog
catcher and it's the same old thing we
need to cut taxes for corporations and
we need to let people do whatever they
want and abuse themselves however they
want we gotta outsource all the jobs
because that's gonna be good for
americans somehow because of some
egghead spreadsheet or something and
it's the same old drone drone
drone that just doesn't seem very
persuasive and then every so often
something shifts and there are
candidates who kind of break that mold
and i am very pleased to be joined by
one of the candidates who is very much
breaking that mold blake masters blake
masters running for senate in arizona
blake runs teal capital and the teal
foundation he has co-authored number one
new york times best seller zero to one
lives in tucson and very very soon we
hope will be representing arizona in the
united states senate blake thanks for
coming on the show
hey michael great to see you thanks for
having me so blake
you are not
uh your run-of-the-mill chamber of
commerce
you know just where is the exact same
brooks brothers suit and says the same
stale talking points you're a little bit
of a different candidate how how are you
different from the typical old stodgy
republican we've come to expect
yeah you know i mean i learned a lot
from president trump i think he came on
the scene in 2016 and he busted up the
establishment he was willing to say
things
that were true that we sort of all knew
were true but you couldn't quite say as
a conventional politician
like he was just on the debate stage in
2016 saying the iraq war was a mistake
turned out to be a big disaster i think
that's how most of the country felt but
that was still not something that
republican politicians could say um and
so i'm out there on the campaign trail
trying to tell people what i think you
know i think i've got a beat on what's
gone wrong in this country not just in
the last nine or ten months of the biden
administration although so much has gone
wrong
but actually just going back a few
decades you know i think the rot in our
politics is pretty deep and i think
people want um you know smart especially
young
new leaders that are going to call out
problems and not be politically correct
and just try to tell people the truth i
think somehow that's
really kind of contrarian today well i'm
glad you've made this point too on
biden yes biden is in extreme failure as
president he's basically everything he's
touched has turned to ash and he's been
kind of a dunce for his whole career but
it's not
just biden and one of those stale lines
that we've heard from republicans for so
long is you know everything republicans
do is good and everything democrats do
is bad and every problem in the world is
because of joe biden or just fill in the
blank of whatever democrat and what
you're pointing out is
in recent decades republicans have made
a whole lot of mistakes too
yeah like i think reagan was a good
president and we rightly look back at
reagan with with fondness i mean i think
he did what he needed to do in the 80s
right we won the cold war we defeated
soviet communism um that that was all
great
and then i think trump did what he
needed to do in 2016. i think he saved
the country from the hillary clinton
administration right um
but what happened in between and i think
republicans just got complacent and they
got comfortable uh comfortable playing
defense and it was just sort of george w
bush you know like i'm a good guy and
we'll just we'll have some good faith
disagreements and in retrospect i think
the george w bush administration was
really bad like we got the iraq war and
trillions in spending and they
centralized education policy you know
with no child left behind
in dc
and we didn't even get a whole lot of
cultural or social conservatism because
it just led to obama
and so
with the republican establishment that's
just content to play defense and just
kind of more or less mindlessly repeat
whatever reagan said in his time i think
the party just kind of fell asleep at
the wheel
and and you know we see the results it
just doesn't work and then we got trump
and i i agree with you
trump was so much better than any
president in my lifetime unfortunately i
just missed reagan you know i was born
under bush the first and so i you know
was bush the first and then clinton and
then bush ii didn't that didn't really
work out and obama was awful then we got
trump and it was really great and i
thought here's the beginning of
something new and exciting in the
country but then then he lost
re-election or
some people think maybe he didn't lose
re-election i mean he practically
obviously he's not the president right
now but
some people have a lot of questions
about the 2020 election
well i'm one of those people um i think
it was messed up you know there's a lot
of wild stuff out there and not every
theory is true of course right
um
but the the media the blue checks the
sort of credentialed you know corporate
media they want to gaslight us and
insist that this was the most perfect
election of all time and of course it
wasn't it just demonstrably wasn't you
can go through six or seven things even
before election day that just make this
thing so messed up like i started to get
really worried in
probably like august of 2020 when you
started to see these headlines right
these seemingly coordinated news
headlines because this is how it works
right there's talking points and all
these different left-wing outlets just
sort of you know deliver different
headline versions of it and they were
starting to say
don't don't expect results on election
night
right like you michael you're not
expecting results on election night are
you well
they were priming the country to accept
the chaos you know that that would come
after the election and um and then of
course you had big tech censorship i
wrote an op-ed with jd vance in the new
york post about this um
facebook and twitter censoring the
hunter biden laptop story
just saying 100 million americans
couldn't read that anymore because
that's misinformation they did that
three weeks before the election but
that's true information from a true
newspaper that was bad for joe biden and
the official margins in this 2020
election were so thin
were so small that i think even that one
brazen act of corporate censorship could
have swung the election let alone mark
zuckerberg personally spending 420
million dollars on allegedly neutral
election administration right you look
at how that money was farmed out it was
super partisan so i think the scales
were were super tilted i don't think we
had a free and fair election yeah and
and some of it you know some of it was
unfair in the way that might be legal
but it really seems to raise a lot of
questions some of it was just clearly
illegal and if you look in pennsylvania
for instance the the use of widespread
mail-in ballots in clear violation of
the state constitution no matter what
the state supreme court has to say i
mean there were all of these problems
you mentioned big tech if three
billionaire oligarchs led by hipster
rasputin jack dorsey if they're going to
control speech in a republic they're not
just controlling one aspect of the
society they're controlling the whole
way that the government is administered
right we we govern ourselves by
persuading one another and communicating
so i think you're absolutely right and
the fact that you're willing to risk
being called
an insurrectionist uh terrorist or
whatever nonsense you know the blue
checks are going to say i think that
that shows a lot of courage but
one aspect of your campaign that has not
gotten a ton of play and i think it
should it it's not just relitigating
what has happened in the past but you
are looking down the line on issues that
will affect the country not just a year
or two from now but decades and decades
from now you're looking at the collapse
of the american family and what it is
that we as republicans or conservatives
or americans broadly can do about it
yeah i mean i'm a super pro market super
pro business guy um i really am but i
think markets are tools for human
flourishing like this the the free
market is not some some ultimate goal
you know the free market is one of the
most powerful ways we have to achieve
the ultimate goal which is human
flourishing which is successful human
families right which is a strong
american middle class
and i think for too long again
republicans got stuck in this rut where
they would just repeat sort of reagan
economic orthodoxy
and you you know they they bury their
head in their in the sand and it's like
a bunch of ostriches just with their
head in the sand and you're failing to
pay attention to the consequences of
your policies
well with all the offshoring um you know
with all the sort of pro big business
policy
uh that we've had in the past few
decades
i think big business has done great
increasingly big business is left wing
and it's sort of fused with you know
with state power in very problematic
ways but the middle class has not done
great the middle class has been hollowed
out and it's harder and harder to start
a family
family formation is being delayed people
our age right millennials
we're not getting married as much we're
having fewer kids and later and this is
kind of a disaster because i think if
you can't
participate in an economy and you know
actually have a reasonable expectation
of getting married and having kids and
raising a family
starting in your late 20s then like
what's good that's gdp may be like super
high
but what good is it for if the middle
class in america is just getting
hollowed out you know this reminds me of
a point that the english writer gk
chesterton made which is one of the
things that's gone wrong in the world is
not that the vices have have run wild
it's not that the world is too bad it's
that the virtues have run wild and in
many ways the world is too good and
that's that's what i'm hearing when you
mention the markets yeah we love the
markets we want a robust economy but
you don't want to put the cart before
the horse you don't want to pretend that
that gdp number is the be-all and
end-all and purpose of government and
society know that the economy is there
the markets are there to support
human flourishing and that means robust
families that's the bedrock political
unit that means making sure actually
this is another point that you've
brought up that sent shock waves through
the republican establishment you think
that you think we ought to go back to
the old timey terrible days when a
family could support itself on one
income
it's amazing to me that that's always so
controversial whenever i say it all i
say is in america you should be able to
raise a family on one single income
right we used to be able to do this
my grandfather did this he weighed nails
at a steel mill in pueblo colorado for
30 plus years
they were able to do that you know
relatively modest house but
one car
you know week-long vacation every year
and um that that worked there was
something about the economy where that
could work and now after decades of
inflation and you know wage stagnation
and offshoring de-industrialization you
can't really do that anymore and it may
be a hard problem to solve you know have
some policy ideas on how we get there
but it's so fascinating because whenever
i just articulate that as the goal
the left freaks out they want to say
that's sexist or they want to say yeah
exactly your point right that's
retrograde you're just trying to live in
the 1950s and it's like maybe both
parents and household want to work like
if both really have great careers and
they care about that great i'm not
trying to tell anyone what they have to
do i'm just saying wouldn't it be nice
if that was a choice
and some some people don't like that but
i think that's the future and the
political party that figures out how to
actually deliver that reality i think
will govern successfully for quite a
long time i know so many young women
young mothers who and when i say young
mothers i'm talking about millennial
young so like 33 you know it used to be
you'd have kids much younger than that
but but because of the problems you're
describing people keep delaying these
things so you know
by today's standards a relatively young
mother say late 20s or early 30s
wants to stay at home and raise her kid
i have a young child you know a 10 month
old baby and he needs mommy and they you
know it's an exhausting it's a full-time
job to raise a kid but now that's very
difficult and so what happens is you
have to send the kid to daycare very
shortly after the kid is born in a lot
of cases so that
i
my wife needs to go out and work for
some other guy so that she can make
money so that i can pay some other woman
to raise our kid does that seem like the
most efficient way the the best way to
to have a family in the united states
seems a little inefficient to me
it doesn't to me personally you know i
mean my wife she stays at home and she
uh takes care of the kids we have three
three boys they're seven five and one
and a half and she homeschools them you
know i try to pitch in on the margin but
i'm busy
campaigning and you know i still have my
my day job and um
but but she feels like that's her
highest calling you know she was a
preschool teacher before
and it's just what she wants to be doing
um so look if not if people disagree
like fine go get a job and pay a nanny
but you shouldn't have to do that you
know that shouldn't just be the default
assumption i think it's weird that it's
become that and i think republicans are
complicit too because again
you said you kind of implied it didn't
make sense and it doesn't make sense
from the family perspective but the way
it makes sense is in the gdp you know
lens if you just view everything through
the lens we need to maximize gdp well
you've got the husband working that his
income's contributing to gdp now the
wife is two and now we're paying the
nanny so we've got three incomes look at
all this economic activity that's
happening and it's like well is that
what the parents want is that what is
that what's best for the kids you know
these things are a little bit harder to
measure and we have such a measurement
bias we just gravitate towards things
that we can measure well you can measure
gdp
but again if you just maximize for that
and you dial everything else back maybe
you end up with this really weird
society and i think it looks a lot like
the society we have now for for so long
republicans would make fun of democrats
and they'd say the democrat the leftist
approach to politics is who cares if it
works in practice does it work in theory
you know we're the conservatives we're
really practical well all too often
you've seen conservatives become these
egghead
spreadsheet loving
theoreticians who who are pushing a
vision and a narrative that is really
divorced from the reality on the ground
you know for so long especially in the
last 20 years you'd hear republicans say
everything's going great for amer for
the middle class americans it's great
look at my spreadsheet look at my gdp
counter well how about look on the
ground in america you've got families
falling apart you've got for goodness
sakes the average life expectancy
declining in the united states because
of deaths of despair i mean that so
these are these are huge generational
problems and i i do think you've got
you've identified them so then what do
we do senator masters makes it to
washington d.c
what what is the first sort of
legislation that you start pushing
day one is just closed closed the border
to illegal immigration um you know
bernie sanders used to be free to talk
about this he knew that unlimited
illegal uh immigration actually
depresses the wages for working-class
americans
for the last five or ten years he hasn't
really been able to talk about that
because the left wants open borders i
think for maybe
electoral purposes later down the line
but you know stop the stop the glut of
illegal immigration i think we probably
have too much legal immigration too most
people are shocked on the campaign trail
when i tell them that we actually accept
more than one million
legal immigrants every year you know
with various kinds of visas and i've
seen in silicon in the silicon valley
context the h-1b visa system is
completely abused you know of course
facebook would love to import tens and
tens of thousands of software
programmers from india and pay them less
money than they would have to pay you
know a us citizen to do those jobs but i
think we gotta you know drastically
curtail if not like end that program
because i think american jobs by default
should go to american citizens
but broadly you need policies that a
raise wages and b cut costs you know the
cost of health care and education and
housing the step just goes up and up
every year and we get used to that we
start to think of it as like a law of
physics
but actually when you zoom in on these
industries there's a lot of regulation a
lot of bureaucracy a lot of sort of
cartel like monopoly like behavior
and i think if you go in with the with
the sort of machete and you you
intelligently sort of hack through the
the brush there's a lot we can do to
make sure that we can build more housing
that we can deliver health care in in
less bureaucratic and less expensive
ways um so if we can get people's wages
to rise and costs to fall all of a
sudden you know five or ten years from
now i think you can get back to a place
where you can raise a family on one
single income i really do you know under
the trump administration for the first
time in a very long time you saw wages
start to tick up again real wages start
to tick up and then the establishment
said no that's enough of that we can't
we can't have too much of that going on
and so there there weren't trump you
make this point which is
politically
controversial among the political class
it's a controversial point among the
american people it's a totally
uncontroversial point namely you think
we ought to
drastically reduce
legal immigration as well as illegal
immigration there was a poll that came
out it was a harvard harris poll around
2019 that asked people their views on
illegal immigration and legal
immigration and
the the phrasing of the survey was such
that they were just talking about
numbers and because as you know most
people don't realize how many immigrants
are pouring into the country every year
when when they were asked what number
seemed about right people settled on
around half a million legal immigrants
coming in every year now of course we
know the real numbers much much higher
than that and so the survey concluded
that the majority of americans that
includes many democrats and includes
many independents
want to drastically reduce legal
immigration as well so why is there such
a huge divide here between an issue that
is very popular among the american
people and unheard of among the
political class in either party
i mean i think you see this a lot i
think the political establishment has
just grown completely out of touch
with everyday reality with what people
actually want but i think there's a lot
of you know the h1b visa system right
like i mentioned the the corporate
interests keep that thing going like
they want that cheap labor
um they just do you know universities
like there's a lot of chinese nationals
studying in the united states right now
and they pay full price you know they'll
get into harvard and they'll pay full
price and of course there's some
low-grade espionage going on there it's
not james bond sexy stuff but like
they're they're recording stuff they're
sending information back home and um you
know there's a lot of visa overstays
there's a lot of people who are granted
you know status to be here legally after
um after they get educated in the united
states and i think the the incentives of
the universities are to keep that gravy
train going
for as long as possible so i think you
know most of these visa systems i you
know i like the 01 visa if you're like
an extraordinary talented person like i
want the world's best and the brightest
to come here you know if you're a rocket
scientist that's going to come and start
a company great like let's bring you in
but i think that's honestly probably
like 10 000 to 50 000 people a year
um
and that's not just it's not 500 000
it's not a million and so i think we
just need to radically reform these
systems because i don't think they work
to the benefit of the average american
and that should be the fundamental
litmus test of any immigration policies
does this policy make things better for
the average american if it does it's
probably a good policy and if it doesn't
then throw it to the curb now
this lens which makes sense to me
this lens is not very common in the
republican party at least it hasn't been
in recent years which is you're saying
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
push for good policy and i'm going to
oppose bad policy and i'm going to push
for things that make the real lives of
americans better and i'm going to oppose
things that make the real lives of
americans worse because it seems to me
the lens on the republican party in the
republican party for the past couple of
decades is
deregulate deregulate everything allow
the left to deregulate on the social
side and don't really push back too hard
there and then we're going to just
deregulate on the
business side on the tax side on we're
on the education we're just going to
deregulate everything it seems to me the
pitch for republican politicians in
recent decades is vote for me and i
won't do anything
i won't govern you i'll just do the
least i possibly can
it sounds like your campaign pitch is
different
yeah i mean i've you know i just i feel
like i've grown up watching the
progressive left just be completely
ascendant they've taken over almost
every single institution in our country
right they run the government right now
but even the social and cultural
institutions look at the look at the
church look at formerly neutral
institutions or center-right
institutions like the military
you know you've got general miley up
there testifying about white rage and
how he reads mao and marx and he's
teaching soldiers about critical race
theory and meanwhile like they forget
how to win wars
um you know i think it's just such a
disservice to the the service members
actually
but
the progressive left is ascendant and
they intend on
concentrating power
on on monopolizing it um
they really do want a a sort of one
party i think totalitarian state like
that's that's what they want and so if
they're going to use political power you
know they have no qualms about that they
don't care about the constitution they
don't care about the rule of law we do
care about that stuff on the right
except like you said most republican
politicians they just don't want to do
anything they just want to play defense
and if you just play defense if you
don't want to use state power to
actually you know make a safe and
functioning society for people and the
left is just going to use that power
then you're going to lose
and that's why the left has taken over
and so this sort of libertarian
republican thing i'm sympathetic to it
because i don't you know i'm cautious of
government power
unlike the left but if we don't stand up
and defend ourselves they will take over
this country and they tell us what
they're going to do they're going to add
states to the union so they can get a
lock on the senate forever they're going
to pack the supreme court they're going
to federalize elections we have to be
willing to use power to prevent them
from being able to do that otherwise
there's no usa in just 10 or 20 years
right well when you say there's no usa i
mean people might think that sounds
hyperbolic but you know what makes a
nation
geographically borders make a nation the
left is trying to destroy that
culturally something in common makes a
nation but the left wants to tear apart
the things that we hold in common and
very often that the kind of libertarian
strain in the republican party has also
pushed back against the ideas that we
have anything in common that we have
mutual obligations to one another that
we actually ought to have some things
that are unifying us as a country one of
the topics that's come up a lot recently
is whether or not the country is just
going to crack up are we going to have
texit are we going to have cal exit
what is it exactly that's going to hold
us together or are we going to go the
way the balkans
i mean i sure hope we don't you know and
i'm i guess i'm optimistic because i'm
running for office i think i can you
know play a
hopefully a pretty important role in
trying to keep things together but i do
think there's some common culture
there's some common bond that we have to
have it can't just be this ideology of
liberalism all the way down where
everybody's just an atomistic individual
and yeah if you have obligations to your
your family or your neighbor um
you know you can't just dissolve those
bonds it can't just be everybody do
whatever they want because i think we
see that that ends in in poverty that
ends in chaos that does end in
balkanization and so i think you know
this is why the schooling issue is so
important we need to teach
young americans new generations to
actually
respect their past
right it's the opposite of this crazy
toxic left-wing stuff that they're
teaching in schools like the 1619
history curriculum which is actually in
some school districts in phoenix it
teaches that the country wasn't founded
in 1776 was founded in 1619 when the
first slave ships came and kids learned
that our constitution
is is discardable and you know evil
because the founding fathers were racist
and i just think that's the biggest
difference between the progressive mind
and the conservative mind the
progressive sees that okay the past
wasn't perfect and so you throw out
everything or the the you know society's
not perfect today we don't live in a
perfect country i think it's the best
that's ever existed but it's not perfect
and so they want to say because it's not
perfect burn it all down and that's the
bolshevik mentality whereas the
conservative says yeah it's not perfect
but let's work to make it better and
let's keep and understand and respect
everything good that's come before us
right that tradition those those bonds
and so that's the fundamental goal is
which way do we break here that's why i
think you know my campaign and my
political uh mission it's this war on
progressivism because i do think it's
destroying america and i don't think
that's hyperbole and if we don't do our
jobs in 10 years yeah america is still
here i mean the white house will still
exist but you know it'll be a one-party
totalitarian state it'll be california
just worse and it'll be managed to climb
like western europe and and i think
america and its sort of spiritual sense
will be gone forever well and you've hit
on this issue of education you're seeing
that rot go all the way down this
education issue just cost terry
mcauliffe the governorship in virginia i
mean
by the end of that campaign it was all
about do you have do you the parents
have the right to raise your kids or do
i terry mcauliffe have the right to
raise your kids and fill their heads
with critical race theory and
transgender ideology uh neither of which
are being taught in schools but both of
which are really great and we should
teach them in schools they kept going
back and forth on their line there right
so so what do we do i mean this is an
issue republicans have
brought it up every now and again
usually their answer is you know abolish
the department of education i think that
i think that line of thinking has kind
of
gone away a little bit now we're more
focused on what do we do in the
classroom why is it why is education
becoming the the new grassroots issue
driven movement
well i think it's one consequence one
one of the only maybe good consequences
of the covet pandemic was for the first
time parents actually saw
what was being taught to their kids like
my kids listening to that
crap for eight hours a day
um and so you know you see this sort of
uh reaction against that
whereas before i think the biases to
always think oh the the bad stuff is
happening in other schools right like my
kid's school is fine it's like no
actually here's a lot of evidence that
says your kid's school is really messed
up
and what we have to remember is that i
mean mcauliffe in virginia was dumb
enough to say the quiet part out loud
but this is what this is what the whole
left-wing education apparatus thinks
this is what the teachers unions think
they don't think that parents should be
in charge of their kids education they
say trust the experts it's like
they're they're the failed credentialed
experts the real experts are the parents
and so you've got to put more power back
in the hands of parents i think
i think that means school choice you
know i think school choice is sort of
the civil rights issue of our time
you should not be relegated to some
failing school just because that happens
to be you know your zip code or your
state assignment um i think that if you
know if you're paying
dollars into the education system but
you prefer to homeschool your kid i
think you should be able to get all that
money back or at least a lion's share of
it so that you can homeschool and if you
look at the polling more people would
want to homeschool if they could afford
it and again you can't really afford it
because we live in the society where you
need two incomes to make ends meet but
if if parents could afford to more
people would do it more people would
create sort of neighborhood schools we
want to decentralize you know the the
system as much as possible and put power
back into hands with parents again maybe
hard to do but that's that's the goal
and then policies that work towards that
are almost by definition good well and
so i guess this leads into the the
broader picture too you know yes there
there are some concrete ways to do it
but it's going to be an uphill climb
what about the broader political problem
we touched on a little bit at the top
this problem of election integrity but
really we call it the swamp or the blob
or this ugly connection between the
government and big tech you know we it
used to be public versus private
enterprise now it's a little bit of a
blurrier line between those two and the
universities and the media and the whole
liberal blob working in concert with one
another how is one guy
sharp though he might be
focused though he might be how is some
senator from arizona going to help to
drain that swamp
you know i think just going in with
clear eyes about it i know how hard it's
going to be like i know it's
it's probably literally impossible of
course for me to do it by myself but
i'll try to be uh
try to be a leader and recruit others to
the cause you know i do think one
individual senator actually has so much
more power even legislatively than
people think there's all sorts of
interesting procedural rules and hacks
that you can really familiarize yourself
with um you have a lot of power in that
chamber most people don't use it right
because the whole pressure is to uh to
to go along to get along you know just
do whatever leadership says and i
definitely don't intend on doing that so
i think i can actually be quite
effective um i also want to use the
cultural power of the senate seat you
know i think most there's a handful of
examples that do this but most don't do
this and part of it is yeah can i
inspire a new generation of people to
run for office or to get involved can i
be a messenger uh for the right kind of
ideals we can learn from the left like
the left advances statement legislation
you know that might look um
really crazy or really radical one year
like it's not going to pass but then
they introduce it the next year and the
next year and the next year and pretty
soon they move the overton window so
that that idea is sort of more
legitimated in the public mind and then
all of a sudden seven years later boom
it's law like look i think the green new
deal is still really crazy yeah but it
was um but everybody knew it was crazy
when aoc first came on the scene and
started blabbering about it and now
you know they just kind of beat people
down and we're at risk of passing that
and i think that's a problem and i think
republicans don't don't use those same
tactics but we absolutely can and so i
think you can just get me and jd vance
and josh hawley and tom cotton ted cruz
like we've got a core group and you
throw a few more and all of a sudden
there's sort of a new balance of power
in the senate i think that could be very
very interesting you know i'm i'm so
glad you brought up the green new deal
example i remember when aoc came out
with the green new deal
mitch mcconnell said well we need to
bring this to the floor for a vote
immediately this is the craziest thing i
ever saw and we're going to get you on
the record
well who's laughing now you know it was
crazy it is it remains crazy legislation
but through that persistence through
that willingness to wield power the
power that i guess her constituents
center to congress to wield
it has been normalized and they have
moved as you say the overton window and
it's i i think uh
you you are demonstrating a clarity of
vision here even among your call your
potential future colleagues who who will
be uh more amenable to that view as well
there there is a lot of power actually
in the senate and republicans a lot of
republicans have just derelicted their
duty and given that up for ideological
reasons or for cowardice or for
ignorance or whatever
but now would be the time to use it
the time is running short we don't we
don't have all the time in the world
blake
i have to speaking of time i've taken up
too much of yours where can people find
you
just go to my website which is
blakemasters.com
very direct sign up to sign up to
volunteer very direct very simple sign
up to volunteer donate if you can i wish
campaigns weren't so expensive but they
are so every bit helps but get in touch
and and sign up and and we'll send you
updates blake i wish you sincerely i
wish you the best of luck head on over
to blakemasters.com
to learn more about blake and we'll have
to have you back to check in on the
campaign
sounds great
[Music]
[Music]
you